the news that LE buff was exiting
Transformers was a shock to nearly
everyone the franchise had made him one
of Hollywood's most bankable young stars
but he chose to use that clout to pursue
more artistic independent films instead
as he told the Hollywood reporter's
Awards chatter podcast in 2019 I don't
think there was any acting going on this
was like personality there was no acting
going on for the huge front half of my
career this was all just my personality
exhibited on a camera the key
transitional moment for LaBeouf's career
happened when he starred in 2010's Wall
Street money never sleeps as he recalled
I was trying to shake off Disney I was
trying to shake off Blockbusters as for
the fourth Transformers movie Michael
Bay resisted Studio pressure to recast
Le Buff's role and instead opted to
bring in Mark Wahlberg as a fresh face
for the franchise